[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les bruits de tirs et olives et de
l'amour est dans le pré heureux comme ça
tous les mardis et selon varda voir
revenir sur les cinq images d'hier soir
qui ont marqué qui ont pesé sur l'amour
est dans le pré
l'amour est dans le pré business a
cartonné ça a cartonné 4 millions
qu'elle cent mille téléspectateurs c'est
leader de la soirée et c'est même un
record de saison et réalise 31 % sur les
femmes responsables des achats et
progresse de 360000 téléspectateurs en
une semaine de mars il faudra mettre un
peu plus de retour au pays il a l'air si
les chéris qu'on l'entende mieux et bill
et bah oui il était premier des
audiences
alors on commence par l'image du numéro
5 aymeric celui qui avait reçu le plus
de lettres n'est pas hyper fort dans le
dialogue vous allez voir il dit des
choses qui sont tellement évidente que
voilà parfois il m'a fait la croche pas
tellement mais il est beau gosse 1
franchement il est beau gosse non
comprend pas tout voilà ce qui se passe
entre lui et les bottes pour garder les
petits toasts de tomates et n'a de cesse
automates quoi
c'est qu'au succès des petits berlingots
tu connais pas ah oui c'était bien mais
ça va
et oui alors il ya plein de points et
nous remercions la production d'atp
d'avoir enfin sous titré emeric et
briques il arrive à me filer le mal de
mer en parlant incroyable thierry tu as
suivi toi emeric et ben j'ai vu un petit
peu hier soir n'est pas pas la totalité
parce que c'est vrai que tu dois bosser
mais l'entente qui sont vraiment super
bon bah je voudrais te plaît c'est de
s'aimer mais moi je vous prends ballon
si j'ai des filles jouent au ballon on
passe à l'image du numéro 4 on a vu
vincent [ __ ] des gros vent à sa
prétendante lors d'une brocante regarde
happé par sa passion vincent semble
avoir pris de la distance sur pascal
comme avec le reste du monde d'ailleurs
comme vincent j'étais perdue à labège
pas où il est ah bah tu m'attends pas
quand tu chine touati chine en ont c'est
joli la lingerie blanche brodée
ted williams l'ensemble c'est là la gym
nos grands-mères ça il ya toujours eu
des mains
la belle quand je vois ça je suis
content de ne pas être mariée quoi vous
imaginez rendez compte que le goujat
quoi fouet la presse elle pas si les
passionnés c'est vrai mais enfin quand
même c'est les premiers essais les
prémices
thierry j'ai un truc à te demander est
ce qu'on te demande et dans l'amour est
dans le pré quand tu n'as c est ce qu on
a demandé de faire des choses de mettre
en scène des petits trucs os comptes
actifs
est-ce qu'on a soufflé des petits trucs
à l'oreille pour que tu as maintenant
percer ma se fait dans l'oreille matt
agité une parole ses droits du coeur et
ça sera comme sarah ma maison rona oui
oui c'est authentique mais là je pense
qu'un jour valoriser dans le magasin si
ça continue comme ça toi tu n'aimes pas
tu aimes pas son comportement
non je m'en veux pas comme un sauvage
puis 10 et la bande derrière vérifier si
vous êtes vous oui maintenant mais si tu
es avec moi tu étais pas je vais pas
laisser derrière
[Applaudissements]
or émotions en troisième position avec
toi on rentre dans le top 3 des images
dans l'amour est dans le pré il n'y a
pas que les candidats qui font des
mauvaises blagues
il est aussi la voix off ils ont des
bons auteurs chez m6 visiblement
regarder pour faire monter la
température de quelques degrés notre
pépiniériste à plus d'une bûche dans son
sac
pourvu qu'il ne pète pas les plombs
[Musique]
al'approche des ruches quelques piqûres
de rappel auprès de ces deux ouvrières
sont nécessaires tailler des sapins de
noël c'est pas forcément un cadeau
l'épisode d'hier où il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont dit qu'ils étaient mous du
genou et que toutes les meilleures
punchline venait de la voix off la voix
voilà tout le monde dit tous les
meilleurs punchline c'est karine le
marchand qui les fait en voix off la
voix off
aymeric à plus d'une bûche dans son sac
et dans son froc c'est une bûche ou une
allumette voilà ça c'est très drôle et
c'est vrai que la voix off
il se lâche complètement elle se lâche
complètement karine lemarchand qu'on va
passer au top de l'excès de l'amour est
dans le pré et c'est au maïs et deux
prêtres ont beau garrett et romain ils
ont si pas mal baisées 1 sur twitter
entre les trois hommes y a pas de filtre
c'est comme
[Musique]
du moins c mais douchez
je connais bien les bâtiments d'identité
raconte un peu
sa taille
j'aime bien c'est moi
cm2 en fait je n'ai pas voulu coucher
avec quelqu'un
j'ai répondu hier ça compte pas voilà
tout penser que là aussi ils sont tous
serial est asean et obèses sont naturels
là j'ai pas trouvé dans celui là est
tout à l'heure vous avez dit star
épisode un peu mou ce qui est c'est ce
qu'ont dit les téléspectateurs zac te
ment et ben moi je suis pas d'accord
pour la première fois depuis beaucoup
d'épisodes que j'avais pas du tout aimé
là j'ai retrouvé du naturel de la joie
de vivre de la spontanéité c'est le
meilleur épisode de la saison ça
m'étonne pas que ça tient toujours
d'accord avec personne
ça bouge - ah oui ça bouge avec lui à
l'e3 nicolas pernikoff c'était vous à ce
même à grand chose et puis quelqu'un
quelqu'un à l'ipr c'est vrai qu'il
rajoute avec la voix fait roi bien que
c'est pour remplir un peu et combler le
vide en tout cas hier ça cartonnait
polancec et loin devant être un corps
dedans saison est ce que c'est une
saison réussie
moi je sont vraiment pas je suis
d'accord c'est tout tout est dans la
voix off ils s'entraident écrire
eux-mêmes les vannes pas ce qui se passe
plus rien à ce qu'il y a plus vraiment
de personnages alors ils ont mis un gay
parce que ça marche toujours il fait des
blagues sur les saucisses mais en vrai
on commence vraiment mais c'est vrai on
l'a vu là j'ai touché ses plus sur table
tout le temps au chaud insu c'est moi
qui vais te dire la saucisse un pardon
j'ai entendu une fois début j'ai
parcouru pour regarder et donc vraiment
nos structures mauvaise saison mais elle
va s'y passe c'est juste que cette
saison de trop il est chafouin mais moi
je suis d'accord avec lui a alors
d'abord d'abord le ton d'avoir fait des
commentaires on est entre les grosses
têtes celles des deux ânes non il est si
moi j'aime pas parce que je trouve que
en fait on quelque part en
instrumentalise les agriculteurs alors
je sais que ça cartonne mais moi je
déteste je sais que c'est censé être
drôle mais moi ça me fait pas rire je
trouve qu'il ya un côté un peu complet
fausse complaisance fausse connivence
c'est nos amis on vous adore mais en
même temps on va vous montrer comment
vous allez être heureux dans la vie
c'est juste insupportable
cette mission vous adorez ce que je suis
pas du tout d'accord parce que vous vous
plaignez quand c'est fake mais
l'ajustement il se passe pas grand chose
naturelle c'est naturel enfin ne
comprenais pas ap six passes être autre
chose vous dirai oui mais c'est fait que
l'on regarde au mollet ni pas les hater
il est toujours un peu biaisé on regarde
ça on se moque un peu
on rigole y en a qui sont ceux qu'on
trouve sincère enfin il ya toujours un
temps de 2 d'autre chose
isimedia deux grilles de lecture 1 vous
regardez soit pour les rencontres soit
pour faire l'immersion dans la france
qui nous ont nourris je pense que cette
émission de service public ma chère
alors on va voir la meilleure image
d'hier soir vous allez réagir
elle concerne chaque l'éleveur de vaches
qui nous avait déjà fait comprendre dans
des speed dating qu'il était très très
chaud c'est depuis qu'isabelle et
patricia sont chez lui on a la
confirmation il est très très très très
chaud à l'état les choses
mais j'ai une antithèse du verdict pour
samus après que
comme avec les hommes ça ils sont
disciplinés et disciplinés comme ça toi
aussi 1 les caennais 7 euros par jour à
la ferme après minute faut s'occuper de
m'en aller filmer moins lourdes en quoi
ya une sorte de voyeurisme de l'ain team
qui est complètement enfin c'est un
match où ses confrères thierry ben ça
m'a touché sens en plus parce que son
produit moussant là pour les vaches j'ai
eu c'est moi je suis âgée unter on va se
dire aux il est bien connu de tous les
sports je suis comme dans le temps
autrefois avec la main c'est un des
tapissiers le crayon et ben on la tire
ont pris un bout de chiffon
les fuyards bouyer ce nom mais pas de du
produit chimique lors de ses treize
chimiques vadot les ouvriers ça et
aujourd'hui en france ce débat serve à
revenir sur ballons la télé un d'accord
oui il va jamais j'avais encore ma part
et de mission donc franchement si ça
c'est pas si c'est pas une caricature
franchement on filet d'espoir finir
vendrait sa fille n'aura pas entre mes
commentaires graveleux toujours en
dessous de la ceinture là le mec qui
prend un truc à l'époux de poètes et non
mais franchement ce fou d'emma vrai et
quand c'est pas ça on se moque des mécas
est pas dans une meuf et il s'enfermait
bakouba c'est ça qui fait que c'est un
milieu pardon que je connais bien ils
sont exactement comme ça quant aux
propos du carême le marchand quand elle
va les voir on les portait elle
plaisante avec eux au niveau où elles se
nourrissent qui se disent entre eux et
c'est tout bêtement des chutes et des
boutades française pardon alors pas
chercher plus loin
c'est un rythme naturel comme dit kelly
géraldine d'ailleurs thierry est ce
qu'elle est comme ça karine lemarchand
rees qu'elle est aussi chaleureuse
qu'elle le montre à l'antenne mois
karine que tu la vois l'antenne tu la
vois à la ferme pareil et je me dis
quand même il faut écouter quand même à
sa place parce qu'il ya des agriculteurs
et mais c'est vraiment qu'ils sont
vraiment jamais sorti falloir arracher
les mots de la bouche
seul humain oui c'est pas facile croyez
moi trop michel edouard effet ces deux
hommes est venu dans la manche pour tous
mais qui c'était devenu ce sera notre
débat a trouvé beaucoup à faire tout
drôle cagni conduisait le tracteur déjà
ouais ça me c'est tout michel edouard
c'est vrai c'est merci être aussi tu es
tu étais un petit peu je suis un sacré
d'ailleurs dans l'amour est dans le pré
après souvent par un matin et avait
révélé que tu avais dormi avec une autre
prétendante par un regard de sa rb6 tepa
marque est interdite j'ai eu un petit
coup de crash était d'origine si j'étais
dans mon lit
et puis bénédicte et je l'avais sa
musique fait on a dormi en sommes voilà
mais pour vous faire mal à personne mais
ba a quand même raison du mauvais annick
bain un petit peu c'est normal tu as
raison
guru déjà couché mois
l'autre fille et danser dans la salle
mais pas macho mêlant bas moi auprès de
la salle a juste donné la porte était
ouverte à mes shows les deux entrées
même toit la pécho les deux ou trois
ballons devant la jauge de jardin bien
sûr
[Rires]
un point tel à cherchell apprenez à les
vues du champ de la chaume avaler que si
tu rentres dans ta chambre tu as oublié
tes cris c'est pas le premier de la clé
était ouvert et la tête toujours avec
annie oui vous êtes price a fait 6 en
vain l'autre jour ça fait six ans que
ces ragots 4 7 ans mais gentil avec elle
c'est un amour nuit ça va bien très bien
je suis content allez les cherry et oui
juste une question la séquence aller
montella est quand même monté au jeu pas
en avant et henri montespan à un moment
donné